foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar flow
virometry sorting b-cell cloning and
evaluation cytoflex SRT and vital
research
I am a restone of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Beckman Coulter Life Sciences to
learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box located at the bottom of
your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions we
ask that you participate in the interest
poll at the bottom right of your screen
click on the option that best describes
your answer
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
John tiggs principal associate in
medicine Harvard Medical School James
McCracken commercial product manager
flow sorters at Beckman Coulter life
sciences
and Cecilia cavazoni research fellow at
the sage lab transplantation Research
Center Brigham and Women's Hospital
John James and Cecilia you may now begin
your presentation
all right hello everyone and thank you
for attending this uh this webinar
sponsored by Beckman Coulter Life
Sciences my name is James McCracken and
I am a commercial product manager for
Beckman Coulter life sciences and I'm
responsible for our flow sorters
including the cytoflex SRT we're going
to highlight some work today done in the
Boston area in uh with John tiggs and Dr
Cecilia cabazoni and how they're using
the cytoflex SRT and some work in flow
varometry sorting and some b-cell and
cloning cloning and evaluation projects
there in the Laboratories
I'd like to give a quick introduction to
the cytoflex platform overall
and what that looks like
so the cytoflex platform is a
commercially available flow cytometry
platform that's based on APD detection
technology Avalanche photodiodes highly
sensitive and very small in size
resulting in really small bench top
sized instruments initially we launched
these as analyzers we currently have
three different models covering one to
six lasers up to 21 color detection with
automation integration possible and
plate loaders
the next Evolution for us uh was moving
this into a cell sorting platform trying
to keep that small size and ease of
operation that the cytoflex analyzers
were known for
with the SRT we top out at a four laser
15 color system with four populations
total possible to sort with mixed mode
sorting capabilities and the ability to
sort in up to 384 well plates
now another nice thing about this is
these are easily parameter matched to
analyzers so when you have a laser and
band pass match between your analyzer
and your sorter you can easily transfer
your experiments between analyzer and
sorter without having to redraw regions
or recreate statistics
so what is the cyflex SRT in a very base
sense we tried to make it the cytoflex
that sorts so you see the same things
you see with your cytoflex analyzer
because of its similar performance and
similar Optical components
and makes a really sensitive Sorter and
in fact is more sensible sensitive than
many flow cytometry analyzers that are
on the market and again making that
direct link between the analyzer and the
sorter platform
just like the cytoflex analyzers we've
tried to simplify an automate workflow
wherever possible right so automating
drop delay determination to make sure
your sort remains stable
keeping that small footprint getting a
system that's ready to sort quickly and
and uh you know easy one-click
interfaces to get uh to get quality
control done and get your sort set up
ready
uh this is an example slide of what uh
configurations are currently available
for the cytoflex SRT we have violet blue
yellow green and red lasers available
and multiple configurations to to meet
the needs of your lab now and in the
future important to note these are field
upgradable and Optical filters from your
cytoflex analyzer are exchangeable with
what's in the cytoflex SRT
I think one of the important things to
highlight for the work you're about to
see
um and and for your own work is the high
sensitivity the cytoflex analyzers are
known for we've carried that over into
the cytoflex SRT cell sorter right so
this is just some example data with
eight Peak spherotec beads which is kind
of our standard and you can see in the
majority of our channels we're able to
see all eight of those Peaks except in
some of these longer Stoke shift
parameters in the Violet laser
we've also carried that sensitivity over
into scatter sensitivity with Violet
side scatter when you have a violet
laser configuration active you can
detect up to 200 nanometer polystyrene
particles so allowing us to get into
sorting very small nanoscale particles
and of course very high fluorescence
sensitivity because of the Avalanche
photodiode detection systems
one of the pieces of feedback that I
think really uh impresses me about
cytoflex analyzer still is how much
people enjoy site expert software and so
when we develop software for the cyflex
SRT we did not rewrite anything on this
we kept things very much in the site
expert mold so that someone who knows
side expert to begin with has a very
short learning curve things are going to
look the same in terms of creating plots
creating regions just some extra icons
to allow you to start sorting
um and of course that's part of what
makes it possible to turn these analysis
experiments easily into sorting
experiments taking those files directly
from your analyzer and loading them into
a sorter
and last thing I'll kind of say here
before getting to the scientific meat of
this talk that's uh that's the main
point is I think the the result of all
this work has resulted in a really fast
adoption in shared resource settings
such as in John's Lab at Beth Israel
Deaconess uh this is an example from uh
from another user's lab showing multiple
researchers signing up to both run their
own sorts or run sorts with supervision
so really fast adoption in these shared
resource settings I think as a result of
these automated features and easy to
interact with software
now before we get to John and Cecilia I
do have to say that the portions
following this are just sponsored by
Beck mccolter this is scientific content
from this point on non-promotional and
purely for educational purposes right so
our products are are have specific
intended uses these cytoflex SRT is a
research use only instrument that's
clearly marked by us and that the views
and opinions that are going to be
expressed by John and Cecilia are uh are
their own and don't necessarily
represent
um Beckman Coulter itself
and so now I'd like to turn it over to
John tiggs principal associate in
medicine at Harvard Medical School and
um important member of the shared
research resource facility there at Beth
Israel Deaconess Medical Center
John
thank you James
so as James said
um this is research use only just want
to reiterate that so that there's no
confusion on on that on anybody's part
um so basically today we want to talk a
little bit what's labeled here as flow
varometry but talking about virus-like
particles and so I did a little bit of
searching and found you know this is
obviously become such a Hot Topic with
all the vaccinations that are happening
these days uh and with the past pandemic
so just found a few companies and how
they're using these virus-like particles
in order to tackle uh vaccination and
possibly alleviate some of the issues
that had transpired during the time of
covet 19. so as you can see here there's
some using what they call a shell and
protruding domain for norovirus capsids
there's another one using norovirus
others using different types and so this
is something that has this grab
popularity I started thinking about a
little bit more and started
trying to see inflow cytometry how we
could tackle this and simply
put it was a something that had been
done previously and we'll get into that
in a second so here's what we were
looking at you see that there are
different ways to form a virus like
particles through bacterias yeast
plants uh you know I've seen drosophila
mammalian cells is one of the more
popular that that we deal with and so
they're looked at for vaccination type
purposes and cancer infectious diseases
as I've already mentioned and so
it's something that started to pique the
interest right and I've been contacted
in different
aspects of
how can virus-like particles be be used
how can we characterize how can we get
them into more of a purified form and
you can see that in the upper left is
that's one of the main things right the
clarification the purification and what
they're calling polishing and so one of
the tools that we've always had at our
disposal is cell sorting
and so as a shared resource laboratory
director
um this for a flow cytometry core this
is something I've been doing for a long
time and so that's the first thing that
kind of popped into my head and so as
you can see here as they administer and
the reason I put this slide up on the
right hand side is simply to kind of
tease a little bit what uh Cecilia will
be talking about and you know talking
about immunity and the immune response
and so
hopefully we can paint this entire
picture of looking at this from the
perspective of how do we get these
virus-like particles how can we make
them pure and then how can sorting go
from the whole
you know
isolating to an actual effective
vaccination
um so let's kind of dive a little bit
deeper into that
so what's the big difference right
virus-like Pro particles versus the
conventional vaccines that we know
whether you know uh these are in the
form of
uh mrnas that have become very popular
or the the old kind of attenuated
viruses so conventional vaccines are
saying there's problems with uh
reversions to burn forms you know
toxicity with you know immunocompromised
individuals it can be problematic in the
uh Elder populations
um
it harder to kind of get out a huge
yield as we saw there were some delays
so everybody started looking at these
virus-like particles in order to put
things with inside them uh and they're
not infectious so you can actually
develop an immune response uh from the
antigens and the animal you know that
you may add to these or things that are
put into the as subunits
um and it was found that they didn't
have any kind of allergic reaction that
you may get from a peg that was used in
the formulation of the most recent
vaccinations uh
safe for these immune compromised or for
you know like we said the elder
population and so less kind of um
issues that that could be formed um
they're still going to be obviously and
we've seen some of them and can talk
about that a little bit but they give
the opportunity to be a lot more
effective and easier to produce and
change throughout different types of
vaccination needs
so let's add to that and see how we did
it so now here's the thing I started
going back and thinking of some
colleagues that I have uh veritang here
and Joshua Welsh and Jennifer Jones
um and then a paper that we had done
along with Dr garon uh where we started
doing these uh looking at extracellular
vesicles looking at retroviruses and
these were used for standardization and
particles that we for reference and
things that we could uh do with the flow
cytometer
and in those type things where we were
looking for reference particles you can
see here that one of these is actually
engineered retroviruses this was a
muscle chemia virus that was from
veritang's Lab that she worked with
Joshua Welsh in order to start to
characterize instrumentation to
standardize instrumentation
for looking at extracellular vesicles
well it just so happens that viruses sit
in the same realm right same refractive
index
sizing is basically the same so the
thought process is well if we can do
this kind of work using say the cytoflex
S platform then we should be able to
translate this over to virus-like
particles
we have a collaborator that uh is at
Boston University and works in the
Infectious Disease department and so
they've been producing these virus-like
particles for uh way before the pandemic
happened and we had used some of these
in our own studies and you can see here
it's a a simple
um taking of the the virus-like particle
in this particular instance being from
uh human uh HIV so human
immunodeficiency virus they are uh
add into a co-transfection with heck
293ts you take off the super name and
you get a bunch of these virus-like
particles with all the same aspects
without the infectivity
so as I you know again thinking about
this we went okay well
how about that classification how about
the purification and so the
classification we had already started
doing in the sense of using the cytoflex
S platform and running these through
certain protocols in order to understand
the size the refractive index and uh the
tagging so these have fluorescent
proteins
so what we did is we used a software
known as uh sorry we'll get to that in a
second
um
just using a software to get that
information and so part of that was
going to this characterization and
purification
looking at the S understanding what it
could do and then knowing that we had at
our disposal at the cytoflex SRT or as
James so nicely put it the cytoflex that
sorts so having the same Optical bench
our assumption which happened to be true
is that we should be able to get very
similar if not exact same results so
complementary type Platforms in order to
advance the science so we knew we can do
things like this this happens to be a
virus-like particle that we're looking
on a scatter plot and then looking at it
using the software I'm about to talk a
little bit more about which is known as
fcm pass in order to tease out the
information of sizing
and then if we could duplicate that same
thing on the platform that is the SRT we
could take this further and not just
characterize but we can move on to this
purification stage
and so that's where our experiments kind
of began and it became very simple so
the first thing we needed to do was grab
ourselves a set of uh beads these are
nist standard beads they're polystyrene
with known refractive index uh and known
sizing so the the nominal diameter is
known along with its actual refractive
index and all this can be converted so
that you understand
um the limits of detection for your
particular instruments and possibly any
corrections that can be made whether by
yourself or a service engineer so there
are a multitude of things that have to
be taken into consideration which is Way
Beyond the the uh the breadth of this
particular talk but is things that need
to be taken into consideration and you
can see that in many of the position
papers such as the myself reports but
simply uh we were looking at our
cytoflex s we did a calibration we
compared that to the calibration that
was done on the SRT and we had
pretty similar results that we had
anticipated previously and now we were
able to prove it now I'm showing just an
example of this but we have we do this
every time that we set up an experiment
and know that just like if you were
doing your QC uh in QA you'd understand
where things started to change well
we're monitoring that and this this is
very helpful to do that with the bead
set and the software our limited
detection is slightly different as you
can see from the lines here on this
bottom graph which is the scatter
diameter curve uh and on a scatter plot
we're able to get a little bit better
out of the cytoflex S than we are the
SRT but we found when looking at the
actual
um
Earth's equivalence so the uh the
or mesf the equivocal uh fluorochrome
insoluble fluorochrome I think it is in
reference for our Chrome on the earth uh
that we could see that the apds and how
they're detected through the instruments
are they are not they are the same it's
not even complementary at this point
they are the pretty much the same dead
on uh so we were able to move along with
this and say okay well let's
characterize and then let's move it out
all right so as you can see here we were
able to take what we had characterized
previously from using the cytoflex S and
through other orthogonal methods and we
move that to our cytoflex SRT so that we
could try and purify these populations
so by getting uh these vlps from our
collaborator as mentioned before they
are labeled with fluorescent proteins
one of them happens to be gfp and the
other one TD tomato so we took these as
a separates each on their own and did a
quick sort of the material and so we
were able to see here how we're taking
this population that has this excess and
we're going to talk about that a little
bit why there's all this kind of
negative
populations in there also it's twofold
one is there is a level of signal to
noise ratio issue at the lower ends of
detection hence the limited detection
needs to be determined
and also there's going to be some
discussed about what else that may
possibly be but as we sort of them you
can see here we were able to increase
the population so all we're really
trying to do is purify and get a you
know a lower yield doesn't really matter
to us as much as having a pure and uh
homogeneous population
but that never satisfies I mean we're
like any good scientist
um if you show us something that works
our next thing is to ask what else we
can possibly get so what we did is we
took those same things we looked at the
vlp gfps and TD tomatoes and what we
wanted to do then is label them even
further so what we did is we took them
and we added what is known as an aco490
die from a company known as acarella
this is a spin out from a lab in the
National University Singapore these are
lipid dyes which are florogenic so hence
they must get in between the lipid
bilayer of the vlps and or an
extracellular vesicle
and then they will become fluorescent
here you can see these are some
extracellular vesicles that we uh
isolated from red blood cells labeled
the membranes with the uh Echo 490 dye
which has a similar uh fluorescent
submission as a chrome rx-525 on a
cytoflex
we then took that die and added it to
our vlps which already had the
fluorescent protein and as you can see
here we get a double labeling of the
virus-like particles but we also get
populations of
you know the there on the Chrome Orange
detector which would be the Eco 490 that
is not actual gfp and as we started to
look at these on the microscope we
realized that the dye is showing us that
when you're culturing these say with the
heck 293 T cells and you're taking the
supernatants even though and you're
doing a purification you're purifying
for a size and density that is similar
to a vlp hence EVS so we were able to
find that under doing microscopy
electron microscopy that we could see
extracellular vesicle populations also
within the supernatant of these
populations hence the need to purify so
this again just proved to us that what
we were actually looking at and trying
to perform was even if just for our own
purposes dude going to be useful
so we looked at the individuals I did an
overlay to show that okay in an overlay
they should separate very nicely we
shouldn't have a huge overlap we've
proved that these populations again ha
are virus uh like particles because they
die with they label also with the
membrane dye and so we then uh plot mix
them together and plotted them out here
it is on the uh portion where my mouse
is hovering that is on the cytoflex S we
converted this experiment using the SRT
software into the SRT so that we could
have two populations and you can see
they look somewhat differently but
that's simply because of scaling and how
we decided to put them on the scale as
the both of the systems are a seven lock
decade and we just kind of stretch them
out a little bit more here so we could
you know for context basically and for
Aesthetics when we're showing them in
presentations such as this
and so we gated the two populations
and lo and behold
we were able to separate them out from
one another hence showing that if we
could you know if you fluorescently tag
these and it didn't matter it doesn't
matter we have access to TD tomatoes
gfps and cherries
um just a multitude and so it's it's not
difficult to start setting different
populations or of virus-like particles
and separating them out the uh hopefully
it's very easy to see on your screen is
the middle as we did an overlay of the
fluorescence microscopy that was done to
show how we have the again the vlps in
green and the vlps and TD tomato
and so very successful sort very
successful experiment uh and by no means
am I naive enough to believe that this
is the answer to every vlp uh or
nanoparticle problem it was a fun
experiment that we wanted to show that
we could not only see virus-like
particles but that we could use them
again as biological references
biological controls and in part of our
standardization protocols and as is
listed on the top you can see that they
are very nice because most of the things
that you're looking at in extracellular
vesicle populations these days according
to NTA or pulse resistant sensing are
going to be in that 92 to 110 120
nanometers with a refractive index
somewhere around 1.39 to 1.42 which
happens to be very similar to the
platelet EBS and red blood cell EBS that
are constantly looked at and done
experimented on within you know the lab
that I work with Dr garon and at for our
joint Labs at the NIH and NCI AI
so again very successful that we had
with this and we're going to be working
further and hopefully prove that this is
a viable method for the classification
and the purification of virus-like
particles and things of that nature
now at this time I'd like to turn the
floor over to some more fun science to
Cecilia and so some things that I've
been having the pleasure to work with
her in our lab and so Cecilia
they're all yours
thank you John
okay
so um
I would like to share some of the
experiments we've been doing and the
characterization of the antibody
response to a sarskoff to spike protein
vaccine in mice so this is not a vaccine
that's been used in the clinic so far
it's just recombinant protein that we
gave animal models to just understand
how the immune system responds to them
and I'd like to give you a little bit of
background just before we go into the
actual
analysis of the B cells just to remind
or present to whoever is new to the
topic that when we have a humeral immune
response so the antibody responds we
have some antibodies that are always
present in our bodies and any mammals
also mice as well as humans and then
when we encounter some pathogen or
antigen of any nature we have a first
response that is independent of T cells
and that generates lower Affinity
antibodies but they're promptly there so
they're kind of a first line of defense
as we call them
and then after a longer time we have the
antibodies that come from uh T dependent
response that you can see highlighted in
the slide
um that are higher affinity and they
have been through the process of
acquiring mutations to improve their
affinity and their class switch so we're
mostly IGG that we're going to be
looking at and a lot of people heard
about this a lot recently because that's
what we're aiming for with vaccines so
we want to be able to generate those
antibodies that are high Affinity class
switch then protective therefore
okay so high Affinity antibodies are
derived from B cells that undergo the
process of selection and somatic
hypermutation in germinal centers which
are these structures that are depicted
here and that I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about just because we're
going to look into this phenomenon
um So within the B cell follicles B
cells interact with T cells well they
capture antibodies from follicular
dendritic cells the fdcs that you can
see on the left corner and then they
present antigen to T cells so both B and
T cells have to recognize
um the antigen to be able to interact
and then from that interaction B cells
get a signal to proliferate and mutate
their their receptors which will become
the secreted antibodies
so after the interaction with T cells B
cells
proliferate divide and acquire mutations
and that might or not may or may not
increase the Affinity of the antibody
and so they get to test that when they
interact with T cells again and so they
go multiple rounds of interaction
with T cells to check if the Affinity of
their receptor is increasing or not and
that's what we call selection so the
high Affinity B cells end up getting a
better survival signal and they
proliferate even more and then
eventually at the end of that cycle
which is something we're still trying to
understand what are the factors that
drive that but eventually they become
plasma cells or memory B cells and those
are the ones producing the protective
antibodies we want to have in our serum
circulating to protect us from pathogens
and also the memory B cells that we want
to keep in our system so that if we
encounter the same pathogen again we'll
be we'll get a quicker response to it
so what we did in our Mouse model is to
give the mouse the cuff the sarskov to
spike protein just a recombinant protein
um to to trigger an immune response and
then 14 days later which is enough time
for that process I just described to
start happening we harvest the lymph
nodes that are draining the vaccination
site and then we do multiple analysis as
you can see here we look for antibody
serum antibodies we also phenotype the
cell Spike flow and then what I want to
talk about now is that we sort and
culture single B cells so that we can
assess what what the antibodies they
were producing looked like
so we'll go a little bit more into the
specifics of that so
here's how our our culture system works
so we as I mentioned take out the lymph
nodes from the mice at day 14 after
immunization and then we sort single
terminal Center B cells into a 96 well
plate using the SRT in this case and we
first of all we coat the plate with this
feeder cells that provide signals for
the B cells to survive and then we sort
the B cells on top of them and let the B
Cells Go for six days and then after
that we can assess
um as you can see the yellow wells in
the picture by Eliza we can assess which
in which Wells we had cells producing
IGG and then we can assess the
specificity of those
immunoglobulins to the spike protein
that we gave to the mouse and we can
also Harvest and freeze those cells to
then extract RNA and get the sequences
so we can pair the specificity of the
antibody with the sequence of the Gene
and that's pretty much how you study
immunoglobly in repertoires because
there are two sides of it and if you
look at the DNA or the MRNA you'll know
about the somatic hyper mutation process
and then you need the protein to assess
affinity and specificity
so here's one example when we did it
with all type mice and then we sorted
a ton of cells in this case I'm showing
300 but we did it multiple times
different models so we can see that from
the 300 cells 309 cells we sorted
about 25 percent of them were actually
binding to the spike protein that we
gave to the mouse and then from these we
can also break it down so the spike
protein has two domains S1 and S2 and
the RBG the receptor binding domain is
part of S1 and it is the part of the
protein that the virus uses to enter the
cells so if you have an antibody that
blocks this domain it's most likely
protective so so we can break it down
and also assess the specificity to each
specific domain
so we assess the specificity to S1 S2
and RBG so in this case S1 means not RBG
because RBG is part of S1 as well so we
can see that about half and half of them
are bind to S2 or S1 RBD
and a small fraction of them is you
cannot detect The Binding if you split
the protein and that could be because
the Affinity is lower or it could also
be because the epitope depends on
um the full configuration of the protein
so when you separate the domains you
lose that banking site and so we can no
longer see those antibodies binding to
either one of the domains separate
so one thing we did to explore this
system that we have up and running in
the lab was to study the difference
between a young adult Mouse versus an
aged Mouse because we know that for aged
people getting a good response to
vaccines is sometimes challenging so we
wanted to understand why is that and why
what's different in their immune system
that
makes it harder to respond well to a
vaccine so we use the same strategy and
we got cells out of young adult mice
that we call Young here but they are
adults and aged mice and as you can see
here we did not
um find um smaller fraction of the cells
to be Spike specific so aged mice are
also able to enrich their germinal
centers for Spike specific cells
and they pretty much have the same
distribution in terms of domains as the
young adults although they do have a few
more
um not determined ones which could mean
lower Affinity or
that they bind to different epitopes
than the young mice and this is what we
see by Eliza just to give an idea of um
what the signal looks like when we
assess the specificity
okay so we harvested the cells also for
sequencing so we can assess from the
MRNA the levels of somatic hyper
mutation in those cells and
interestingly we saw that on average the
age the B cells are also able to acquire
mutations but what we found was kind of
a dual pattern here so we find a higher
frequency of cells that did not acquire
any mutations but also a higher
frequency of cells that acquired many
mutations which we called eight or more
so as you can see there are what we call
germline which means not mutated at all
so their aged mice have more of those
but they also have more
um highly mutated cells which are have
eight or more
um mutations in the in the BCR Gene so
we find an aged mice that they're also
able to select for specific B cells in
the journal Center and also able to
accumulate mutations so we're not yet
sure about why is the response overall
worse in aged mice they do have a lower
title of antibodies in their serum as
well just like aged or elderly people
um and but we're not but it's not due to
a deficiency in the selection process at
least it doesn't seem to be as far as we
could assess
and then another uh example of how we
can further explore this uh this
technique or this protocol of culturing
the the single cells
um we can also measure Affinity because
we have the B cells each one
individually secreting their antibody in
a single wealth so when we collect that
supernatant we actually have a
monoclonal antibody in in each well so
so what we did here in this case is not
aged versus uh young mice but is a
different Mouse model where we can
perturb the T cells
so in this case the green pie chart
shows that it's a tfh deficient Mouse so
in this mouse we're able to remove the T
cells that would be giving the B cells
signal to proliferate and mutate so I
put in the right um
tough the picture again just to remind
us that the B and T Cell interaction is
what drives the B cells to proliferate
and accumulate mutations and in this
case in the green
pie charts we're showing that what
happens when we remove those cells that
are able to interact with the teeth with
the B cells
in the germinal center so as you can see
it reduces a lot the frequency of Spike
specific cells so we went from 40 to 10
percent more or less and uh but those
Spike specific ones are still able to
bind
RBD which would be the protective most
likely protective antibodies
and then on the far right on this slide
you can see that it's a kg measure so
it's an affinity measurement so we were
able to use those super Newtons to um
measure affinities with biolary
interpreometry
um and as you can see there with the
green dots so in this case the higher
the dot the lower is the Affinity in the
plot so the higher the kg the lower the
Affinity
um and so as you can see when we remove
the T cells which means in the green
dots we see lower Affinity antibodies
show up
so in the control levels we have
affinities that are pretty high down at
the bottom and which are the blue ones
and the green ones as you can see we
have both so some are still able to
acquire higher Affinity but we also see
some very low Affinity antibodies
popping up so we can actually show that
we can reproduce the phenomenon that
would be happening inside the lymph node
in vitro by culturing the B cells and
then looking at the effect of not having
a T cell in the mouse to
participate in the Affinity maturation
process
so so these are some of the questions
that we've been addressing
um in the BNG cell communication and
generation of high Affinity antibodies
and that we were able to do this using
this single cell culture system
so with that I want to thank you for the
attention and
be happy to take any questions
thank you John James and Cecilia for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started
our first question is
what kind of plate filling Efficiency do
you see in other words how many Wells
actually grow cells as expected
um okay so I think well I I'd say that
our efficiency is around 65 percent at
best but I think it's more on the
viability of the cells so these are
activated cells and they're prone to die
so I don't think that wherever we don't
see cells growing it's not because they
weren't sorted into the well it's mostly
because they just didn't survive
so because when I sequence them directly
I get pretty much close to 100
efficiency so the culture adds another
layer where biology plays a major role
so
at best around 65 percent yeah
thank you
next question
are there clean up steps that can help
with removing debris from vlp sample
preps or are these pretty clean
no there's lots of cleanup I mean
they're pretty clean in the sense of
you know it's a supernatant filled with
you know virally infected uh
cells basically and then budding off but
um
you can use uh basic size exclusion
chromatography
uh there is uh capta core beads that
will
are used for viruses kind of exclusively
with uh from I think it's GE puts them
out so there's definitely some cleanup
methods that need to be done
um to purify and then as we said in the
talk
um
you do have that problem of things that
are same size and and basically density
being problematic also
all right thank you excuse me
um next question and this is for John
is the ac049 die that you used available
commercially and if so what is the full
name
um Echo dies are available commercially
through the company acarella so if you
let's see I believe it's
a-c-o-e-r-e-l-a.com
um
question
if someone can type that in so I don't
have to try to figure out how to do that
um it is available uh
through the website
um and also I believe there's contact
information for uh Sarah uh Sarah Joel
Cox
um who is kind of
sort of the lead from that group to do
that so and they have many different
um colors on that I think from UV
excitation through uh infrared and
actual infrared uh not not just the far
red but actual you know in the Thousand
um so
all right thank you
uh next question
and this is for John can you separate
blps from EVS without a fluorescent
label
eops from EVS without a fluorescent
label no not that I'm well what's the
correct scientific answer not in my
hands have I been able to do this as of
yet uh you'd have to do something to
differentiate between those with and
without Spike proteins
um and I think that's difficult without
actual labeling I mean the whole point
of using a virus like this a vlp is a
and exosome kind of mimic for
standardization and I believe uh the
most common one to use uh is the
recombinant EVS that Sigma puts out it
was the originals from uh on Hendricks
uh in that paper is out there to see
exactly how they are made so I'm gonna
say no
do you use to deplete EVS from your vlp
Preps
again that's very difficult and this I
think is why we see them hovering in and
when we've had discussions with the
group from National University Singapore
and now the acarella company uh it is
thought that that's just the the EVS
that are transferring in so obviously in
the cleanup methods it's extremely
difficult because
well there's a lot of reasons and I'm
sure
out of the scope of just this answer
um
so it is very hard to do anything with
cleanup because if you do a size
exclusion and basically they're the same
size if you do a density gradient
the density is the same you know
anything refractive index same so they
make great EV mimics
all right thank you
um next question
what is the lower limit of sorting blps
could you sort norovirus vlps which are
about 30 to 45 nanometers
um I don't know because I haven't tried
and it's about you know just trying we
have which we haven't shown here because
of what this topic was about we have
done some um omvs which are the
bacterial uh derived extracellular
vesicles and
by using dyes and and stuff you can pick
them out now what you'd have to do is
transfer over to using more of a
fluorescence triggering than you would
scatter scatter The Limited detection of
the instrument I don't think you get
anywhere near it
um but by triggering fluorescence you
can probably pick up either those that
are super bright or I'm not going to
deny that it's possible that if there's
any clustering it actually benefits you
in this instance
all right thank you next question
if trying to start vlp experiments would
you recommend having a Beckman Coulter
technician set up the parameters on the
cytoflex instrument for optimal
resolution
um I think I mean you kind of have to
have them really fine-tune the
instrument now this has been an ongoing
debate on best practices in the in this
instance and a lot of it obviously is
going to fall down on the technician
themselves of having the proper
standards and you know understanding the
instrument but yeah without a a tuned
instrument in the first place you're
never going to get anywhere close to
where you need to be
um fortunate for us we have just a great
team here that understands what's the
what we expect from our instruments and
bring them to that kind of gold standard
so uh having a great relationship with
your engineer is probably the first in
in foremost uh step to your success
all right great thank you
next question this is for John
where are these particles more abundant
do you still need to do a lot of
post-sort concentration
I don't have reference to what the
particles are referring to okay so I'm
just going to make some assumptions
um and say that even though they are
abundant it really depends on what your
Downstream application is so if you are
trying to look for a particular cargo if
you're looking for particular subsets
you're really going to want to do some
sort and tease about based on whether
it's a a surface protein or some sort of
RNA that is internal to the actual
particle
um if we're talking about just kind of
let's just call them I guess uh
hydrogels or something like that
that's different you're hoping you have
homogeneous populations so but if it's
something that's kind of we're talking
either EV exosome virus-like particle
you need something to characterize them
because in these preps like we said
you're going to end up with other stuff
in there so you want to be more specific
all right great thank you and we will
wrap up with that question thank you
John James and Cecilia do you have any
final comments for our audience
James I yeah I think the only thing I
would say is uh thank you everyone for
attending I really appreciate your
questions and um and interaction and uh
yeah thank you very much to Cecilia and
John for sharing your work I really
appreciate it and um I hope everyone
found it as interesting as I did
thank you James
um I will just say because you know when
someone asks can you do this can you do
that
um it's science we try to have some fun
with it so if you can think about it try
it I mean worst case scenario is it it
doesn't work and well that's 98 of all
science so
yeah just have fun with it
oh boy
oh do you want me to ask this there's
one question that came in
we do have a just a couple more minutes
um
so thank you for the great overview
would it be possible to comment on the
feasibility and Logistics of sorting
enough NP like material for Downstream
analysis example proteomics sequencing
Etc
okay from experience
um I'm going to say that for these type
analysis it depends on the actual thing
um what you're doing Downstream pcrs I
think we've gotten away with doing about
sorting out about 40 000 uh positive
particles
for things such as proteomics that
number went up somewhere on a hundred
thousand possibly if more would be
better but I think rule of thumb and
from uh working with Jennifer Jones on
some sorting projects previously uh you
end up to get uh what you would think in
a same as a cellular assay like Cecilia
was talking about we could do you know
singles and get this it doesn't work the
same you can actually end up sorting for
upwards of 72 hours
all right well thank you again John
James and Cecilia for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Beckman Coulter Life Sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
also we encourage you to answer the
interest poll questions at the bottom of
your screen
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye